alright what's more likely how are you
more likely to celebrate a big
professional achievement throw a big
party like Kyle Shanahan or eat a
cheeseburger and sleep like Andy Reid
Chris well ok I honestly I guess if I
have to pick one or one here I'm gonna
say throw a big party like Kyle Shanahan
but I'm really more of like in-between
of both of these like I know the
Shanahan family and I bet you there was
like 60 to 80 people in their house that
have been too much for me after the
Super Bowl
now just eating a burger and going to
sleep that had been too boring I'd have
probably just had really close family
there had a burger and a drink and
whatever else and then kind of called it
quits
at a respectable hour I wouldn't have
partied and you know late into the night
or anything like that or nor would I
have wanted a bunch of people in my
house so I'm really I'm in between but
if I got to pick one of the other I
guess I'd go big party now again for me
getting to the Superbowl would not be
the occasion for it I would be too
freaked out as we've already established
but for the Super Bowl victory we we'd
blow the place out they'd have to burn
it down when we were done everybody I
know would be here we'd book our buddy
young MC to come in and sing bust a move
I mean then it would be upside down
party that would be something that went
into the wee hours of these two things
what are you doing you got to do one of
them throw the big party I'm telling you
aren't a big party on Shanahan yeah
you're not listening to what I'm saying
well I use a Super Bowl win then yes
sure
yeah I would and and I've already said
what I would do after getting to the
Super Bowl I would be too freaked out
about losing the Super Bowl to want to
do anything other than get back to work
all right more likely to be overwhelmed
by the moment in the Super Bowl Patrick
mahomes or Jimmy Garoppolo I'm not are
we doing this to Jimmy Garoppolo why are
we doing this to him didn't we already
do it last week yeah I mean I'm like
Jimmy Garoppolo now really honestly I
think Patrick bones is going to be more
self aware of the moment you know hey
for lack of a better phrase I think
Jimmy Garoppolo is kind of like a
meathead he's just kind of let go I
played quarterback and hey look at me I
got a big chest and I'm handsome and I
don't think he like I don't think like
mahomes I think is going to be very
aware of like my legacies on the line
today today's my day to established
myself is one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and start my
run like I think he's going to be very
aware of that
but I think when it comes to playing I
mean my Holmes is this cool and is calm
and does things is that I've seen no
quarterback ever do at his age so yeah
I'm gonna pick Jimmy Garoppolo to fold
under the pressure I guess more during
the game than then a Patrick mahomes
yeah and look I pointed this out
yesterday and I wrote something about it
and it's fitting that we're going to
Miami for the Super Bowl because the
Dolphins have to Hall of Fame
quarterbacks and Pat mahomes plays like
Dan Marino and Jimmy Garoppolo plays
like Bob Griese JC through seven passes
in one Super Bowl 11 and another one and
if everything goes according to plan for
the 49ers he won't have opportunities to
get freaked out right he's a role player
in in an era where the quarterback is
the most important guy on the field he's
been marginalized by this offense and
he's got no problem with it it's amazing
Chris the quotes yesterday from guys who
otherwise would be part of a passing
game that is now almost non-existent
they don't care you know Samuel is fine
with it
Emmanuel Sanders says I embrace blocking
George Kittel we ran at 42 times huh we
should have gone for 50
it's amazing how Kyle Shanahan has
gotten these guys to buy into yes and
never catching a pass and imagine if
they'd gotten Odell Beckham jr. I
thought of this last night remember they
were in the mixed form yeah how would he
feel about blocking all the time yeah no
I mean you're right I mean he would do
it I think he'd probably want the ball a
little bit more than some of these guys
are getting it for sure you're right but
Shanahan and again this goes into
culture and creating environment and
excitement and Shanahan he keeps it real
these guys understand what the game plan
is and what's gonna happen on that given
week so I don't think their expectations
get too high you know I'm sure those
receivers saw the game plan they're like
man we got a whole lot of run players
and coach seems to be talking about the
run a lot and we're really focusing on
it so I think they got a good feel for
it you got alone he finds ways to get
them the ball in other ways to to where
they know they're gonna have some
they're gonna have some part of the game
you know one way or another but it is
it's a credit to Shanahan that he's got
everybody believing in what they're
doing it's easy to do it when
you win Yeah right doctor you're not
winning yeah then you're gonna have
Scott saying why the hell are we running
the ball all the time of course they
wouldn't run the ball all the time if it
wasn't working that's the thing and
that's the genius of Kyle Shanahan he's
smart enough to not outsmart himself
yeah he's not gonna fall into the
temptation to say well you know we're
running to set up the pass no run to set
up the run and then run some more to set
up the run and until they can stop it
keep running so and and it's so simple
it's so simple that's what makes it so
brilliant no it is it's creative and he
has answers for anything you do and then
they're really good at coaching it on
top of that I mean some of the runs they
ran on Sunday it's it's phenomenal game
planning and coaching how they blocked
it so but your tell are you taking
Patrick of a Holmes to be overwhelmed by
the moment over Garoppolo you're still
taking Garoppolo because they both kind
of really explained that it should be
mahomes it is mahomes it is mahomes
yeah I for all the 49ers fans out there
who were waiting for us to crap on Jimmy
Garoppolo I'd say it's mahomes because
he is the game plan yeah right - I'm
going to my home still and my answer
said mahomes and I tried to justify it
because he's talented and awesome but no
I think he'll be more overwhelmed and
self-aware of the moment then Jimmy
Garoppolo will be so you're right I'm
changing I'm going my home still I mean
Garoppolo can have a bad game and yeah
they don't win don't win him right go
back and look at Ben Roethlisberger stat
line from Super Bowl 40 it's an
embarrassment cover day one right
because they had the defense in the
running game to make it happen in the
49ers have all right let's shift gears
to non Super Bowl teams teams at the
other end of the spectrum the Bengals
hold the first overall pick in the draft
there's been some reporting about the
Bengals having no intent to trade that
first overall pick no matter what offer
they get Duke Tobin the VP of player
personnel said Monday that's news to me
what's more likely the Bengals draft Joe
burrow with the first overall selection
or someone makes Cincinnati an offer
they can't and won't refuse I think the
bangles drafting Joe burrow I mean you
know he's one of their own in the state
of Ohio he went to high school there
right so they're that they need that
they need the position we know that you
know mean all the you know the
of jobber oh and the the hype around of
is never gonna be higher than what we
see right now and they're gonna kick
themselves two or three years down the
road we talked about this last week if
they trade this away and he ends up
being awesome and year two or year three
they're gonna go man we passed him up to
fall down in the draft and whatever it
may be and the other reason I don't
think anybody's gonna make that huge
offer is hey you know Tula is in the
draft you know Justin Herbert he's a top
ten pick too so I don't know you know
there'll be options there for teams that
do need quarterbacks I guess is my point
so I think the bangles do draft jobber
oh but I will tell you this and I
haven't written this yet at PFT I
mentioned it during the radio hour yeah
the Dolphins love Joe burrow and want
Joe burrow now I don't know how Bryan
Flores feels about it but the guy who
signs the checks yeah
wants Joe burrow and you know this this
is part of the value of the tank that
the Dolphins apparently were in for the
first seven weeks of the season until
they started winning football games but
getting that number one overall pick
means you control the board and you
either get Joe burrow or you get a lot
in exchange for the privilege of someone
coming up and getting him in there the
Dolphins at number five and if you're
the bengals you could drop down to five
and still take two up davin right or
look at the draft capital all the draft
capitals the dog that the Dolphins have
to try to make that move if they decide
to do it but the guy who runs the
dolphin Stephen Ross my understanding is
he loves Joe borough and we got a couple
of months to see it out how that all
plays out but it you know I could see
somebody trying to do it Chris and I
think right now it is more likely the
Bengals take him yeah but I think it's
gonna be a story we're gonna be
following very closely because I think
other teams will be plotting ideas for
how they could get up there and maybe
get it ya know and it's early I mean you
know I I haven't started watching film
of these guys yet you don't have a lot
of the important decision makers in the
NFL have not done a deep dive into these
players yet so you know it is early to
see where this all goes and I mean
certainly just here watching TV and
everything we saw Joe burrow does seem
like the number one pick but you know
maybe that changes maybe he does fall
down a little bit but I doubt that I
don't see that happening that's a really
good point that's what Duke Tobin said
when he was asked about it we
don't know what we're doing it's still
early in the process Ellie no no you
know who the number-one guy is it could
be somebody other than jobber oh by the
time we get the hay in the barn right on
who the topic is we've seen that happen
before Mario Williams ended up the
number one pick in 2006 when everyone
thought it was gonna be ready fleshly
people thought I was crazy when I was
gonna man I lead in February the year
Patrick mahomes is coming out in the
draft I was like man Patrick my Holmes
this guy at Texas Tech I just watched
him I go this is Aaron Rodgers you're
Brett Favre I mean this is the number
one pick in the draft
and I had a lot of people in the NFL
reach out to me that were you know front
office guy scout oh you're crazy he's
not the number one pick in the draft but
you know what happened as time went on
the really important decision-makers and
evaluators aka Andy Reid and Sean Payton
they start to dive into the film there
you know and late January and February
and they start to watch and they go oh
my gosh
and yeah that changes everything around
you know everyone told me Matt Barkley
was the number one pick of the draft you
know what happened all the NFL coaches
started watching film and they said holy
crap he's not the number one pick of the
draft what the hell is everybody on TV
talking about and he fell down so you
know that's that's the the big time
decision makers have not gotten there
yet so we'll see where that all goes
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports